I gotta ask you you know was it as kind
of an excruciating weight for you for
this season as it was for the fans of
this show
yes
it's been a long journey you know I
started when I was 23. it's um but it's
well worth the wait my God I'm so
grateful for the fans for sticking
around and just kind of keeping the
excitement just because it's so
so big season two it really takes every
element of season one and blows it up
literally conflict Adventure romance
crime solving all of the things lots of
drama which we love um but it also ends
in the most beautiful way
um but yeah I college people to say it
really I think they'll really enjoy it
so yeah yeah you know that's right you
have been living with vignette for quite
a long time now you know when I was
talking to Orlando the other day he was
talking about
how much passion you have for this
character like how much passion you have
for the role what are you really gonna
miss about having vignette in your life
oh everything I um I miss doing Irish
accent most of all but there are lots of
attributes that I learned you know that
vignette has that I really tried to take
on in my own life like just her ability
to never give up and she stands up for
who she is and what she does so much she
really steps into a huge leadership role
in the second season
um and yeah she gets a bit darker gets a
bit grittier you know in the first
season I think she allows she leads too
much
um from a place of love that allows of
she puts other people's needs before her
within the second season that doesn't
happen as much she's just she's a
warrior through and through and so I
really try and take that on I don't have
the same adversities as soon yet but I
still you know need a warrior
are you gonna miss like the show is so
beautiful and it's hard to tell
oftentimes what's practical and what's
like computer generated effects are you
gonna miss that part of playing vignette
where you get to do all the things where
you're flying and when you know like you
you get to have those Powers I mean I I
wish I could actually fly but I don't
know if I'll miss why I work as much as
but pretending I was lying but like you
know just because it looks easy but it's
painful and but my God I will miss it
I'd still miss every part of it honestly
um definitely this dance is really fun
and when you get it right it's so great
it's I you know I had a stunt person who
made it look so easy so every time I
would get off there I was like okay this
is not a cc made it look so but that was
fun I love challenging myself so
honestly in that way it's so great I
think it's really exciting that the fans
are going to get to see how this story
closes out but do you can you see a
future for these characters like is
there a future where you could say you
know what I like to revisit vignette
maybe if it's even if it's not a series
in another medium
um yeah I mean I think the way that it
ends is you know you'll see it's kind of
so perfect
that I like leaving The Wonder of where
it goes from there
um but you know there's always there's
always an opportunity I would never say
no to that but um you know it ends too
well to like carry it on that's a nice
promise it ends too well yeah awesome
Cara thank you so much for the time it's
a pleasure thank you